hi Mary this is brian gallagher I'm the
CEO of United Way worldwide thanks for
your question I think you're right the
growing disparities both an education
and achievement income is a real issue
and one of the things one of the topics
here at the forum is how do you how do
you create economic success in value in
conjunction with human success and and
we in the in the civil society sector
here will be pushing business and
government hard in terms of excellence
in terms of getting young people and
people generally prepared for the jobs
of the future and also creating economic
opportunity more broadly speaking
because if if we don't get more and more
people succeeding in the new global
economy sooner or later that economic
model fails so one of the things that we
spend a lot of time doing is working
with business working with government
working with educational institutions in
terms of what other than what are the
jobs going forward how do we make sure
that our educational systems as well as
our social systems create opportunity
for people to be successful in in the
new economy and so your your question
spot-on it's going to require big change
on part of government and business and
nonprofits but but but we're committed
to it and your question I think is it's
very appropriate for this year's forum
and thanks